hello
luce how are you oh how are you i'm very
good i'm very good so lewis you are
based out of florida
yes i am tallahassee florida okay very
cool i know what that is when uh
department of insurance is also out of
tallahassee i've been to tallahassee a
few times seminoles
yes yes all of our state all of our
state agencies are
housed here in tallahassee i work for
the florida department of revenue
so you work for the florida department
of revenue tell us what you think
governor desantis is doing and i think a
big part of this was after gerard made a
comment saying he feels
a desantis tulsi gabbard or desantis
mansion you know a mansion a ticket
could be a good one and then i saw your
comment come two minutes after he made
that comment
so what are your thoughts about desantis
what can we know about him
well the simple fact is he's making
common sense judgments
and for as much as you want to hate
republicans and i'm not a republican i'm
an independent
okay but i work with a lot of
democrats and they're following oh you
know
the republicans are out to get us they
hate us and this and that and it's like
and right with with trump they were just
oh the santa is just following trump's
quote tales and i'm like
no you have to look at policy stop
looking at favoritism amen and look at
what is being
done so let me ask you do you like do
you like desantis more than you like
trump
i could i can honestly tell you i like
both
okay um i didn't vote for trump in 2016.
interesting because i'm from new york i
lived in new york okay
we went to school there yeah and i knew
how trump was and i was thinking okay
trump is going to make a mockery of
everything the man is just about for
himself and making a dollar yeah
he will sell us to the highest bidder if
he's president interesting i could hear
that section
yeah i knew it i knew it from the first
first word she said he's already
flirting don't let yourself get you
we want to get value from you tell us
tell us what policies of the sanchez is
influencing the other side trying to get
in with the government the last the last
few especially the one that he most
recently signed recently concerning the
girls
and same-sex yeah playing in sports
that has come that has been a milestone
in leaps and bounds in these last couple
of days in what way
because a lot of people even though they
are
liberal they did agree that that is not
fair
because boys even if they change to be a
girl they're still biologically a boy
they're going to be stronger and faster
than a girl
biologically do you know what she's
talking about
so like technically i could without
transitioning i could technically say
that i was a woman and still have one
year of eligibility left and go play
softball against
17 year old girls tomorrow you break
every record with a metal bat mind you
so i mean it's insanity are you thinking
about it if it was money involved they'd
do it tomorrow
200-foot fences too yeah
yeah so that was one of the most recent
things that has a lot of people
you know thinking twice and it was one
of the things that was happening
especially now when
for re-election i did vote for trump
because in those first four years he did
change my mind
huh interesting so you didn't in 16 you
did in
and now 2020 saying that if desantis ran
so you would much rather have desantis
run in 2024 than trump
um i would i don't mind either one
because
trump has um shown a lot and he's proven
me wrong
yeah in my original assessment of him
the only thing i can be like everyone
else
his delivery on saying things that was
my main issue with him
but it wasn't that he wasn't telling the
truth he was telling the truth no just
needlessly adversarial yeah he can't
help himself yeah i would go with
desantis
totally the less confrontational better
chance to align people
and you know it follows that platform or
jimmy carter turns it over to a strong
governor from a big state ronald reagan
it's interesting that um it's
interesting that you said that the
democrats
uh are are being won over is there
anything in particular that desantis is
doing that's
that's helping to kind of bridge that
gap
it's it's all the little things that
he's doing especially towards state
employees
with us because you know we we just
received a
increase what two years ago and before
that it was seven years before that
you know we have the union that comes
hard at us
oh we need to stop this we need to stop
that however i
because i am considered an exempt
employee
i'm not covered by the state's askme
union i am technically what is
considered i work at the
leisure of the governor if my if
budgeting cuts has so happened to happen
guess what being that i'm a select
exempt employee
minds could be one of the first
positions to go hey i'm not essential
too
yeah awesome louise thank you so much
for this uh appreciate you
uh stay on with us uh we we appreciate
you listening to the podcast thank you
love you guys keep doing a great job
thank you bye bye bye bye bye bye bye
bye
she said common sense influences taking
place she's working for
the state that's pretty weird to be
working for the state you're not making
a lot of money but you're seeing the
different impact taking place
very very interesting so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye